بدوره تفقد وزير الدفاع عن رمسيس سيرجيو
شو يقول قوات الروسيه في منطقه العمليه
الخاصه والمواقع المتقدمه للوحدات فيها
وقالت وزاره الدفاع ان طائره علمتني حلقت
فوق مناطق انتشار القوات اضافت انا شويغو
تحدث مع الجنود عند خطوط المواجهه كما
استمع في مركز قياده الوحدات الى تقارير
من القاده بشان العمليات العسكريه للقوات
الروسيه
الى دنيا اسمها مراسله الجزيره السلام خضر
مع هذه المشاهد التي بثت لشوي وما هي
الرساله التي ارادت منها
بهذه الصور وزاره الدفاع همم بمناطق
العمليات التي زارها واشرف عليها والوحدات
المتقدمه
يعني هي رساله من
مرحلتين انجازه التعبير وتفسير الفيديو
الذي نشرته وزاره الدفاع الروسيه الاولى
موجهه الى الوحدات المقاتله الروسيه عند
الخطوط الاماميه بان القياده موجوده وزاره
الدفاع تحديدا قادره على الوصول الى
المناطق المتقدمه من الجبهات طبعا وزاره
الدفاع لم تحدد المناطق التي زارها ولم
تحدث تاريخ الزياره ولكنها اكتفت بالقول
انه جال عند الخطوط الاماميه وحلق فوق
المواقع الاماني الاماميه والطلعه على
السير العمليات في هذا ايضا رساله الى
الجانب الاخر الى الجانب الاوكراني بان
السيطره الروسيه على السماء لا تزال
متفوقه مقارنه مع الجانب الاوكراني وبانه
وزير الدفاع يستطيع ان يحلق فوق المناطق
الاماميه والخطوط الاماميه من دون ان يتم
استهداف طائرته او رصد هذه الطائره على
الاقل هذا ما يفهم من الفيديو ومن الخبر
التي الذي وزعته وزاره عروسيه طبعا الخبر
هذا نشر بعد يوم واحد من اعلان لكريم عن
ان رئيس الرئيس الرئيس الروسي فيلاديمير
بوتين ايضا كان متواجدا في غرفه العمليات
واتبع العمليات يوم الجمعه الماضي طبعا
ايضا لا نعرف اين تتواجد غرفه العمليات
هذه على الاراضي الروسيه او على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه ولكن لكريم للقاله ان ااه بوت
تواجد في غرفه العمليات وتحدث الى القاده
العسكريين الميدانيين وليس فقط الى وزير
الدفاع او رئيس الاركان رئيس هيئه الاركان
الروسي قال لكريم لان بوتين تحدث مع
القاده الميدانيين والطلع منهم على سير
العمليات وايضا استمع الى مقترحاتهم حول
همم سير العمليات وخطوط تحرك القوات
الروسيه محمد شكرا جزيلا لك السلام نرحب
الان بتامر